Hey Christian, want some water?
>> Hey Don, yes please.
>> Sure.
>> That's a fancy teapot.
>> Yeah, it's one of my favorites. Oh I'm sorry it doesn't have much water.
>> I'd like a little bit more than that.
>> Well here why don't you fill it and I want to explain this coffee pot.
>> Sure.
>> So. This is a joke. It's one of
my favorite jokes. It's sometimes called Coffee Pot for Masochists,
it was done originally by a French artists and this was
a copy made just for me. And I've used it for
the cover of my books, I love it so much. You
know, what's nice about it is it's obvious that you grab
the handle, it's obvious that that's the spout, but it's also
obvious that it's the wrong way, it won't work. The conceptual
model is clear and it's clear that it, well, that it's
a joke. It's impossible on purpose. What's a matter? How you doing?
>> Well I,
it doesn't have a place to fill.
>> Yeah. I know.
>> So
>> I'm not sure I recommend that.
>> Okay. Then the other choice is at the buttom.
>> Hm.
>> Which I'm going to try.
>> Uh-huh. Good. Seems to work.
>> So far.
>> Hm.
That's a
funny way to use a teapot.
>> Yeah, that doesn't seem to work.
>> That's not the way I used it before. Hm, hey.
>> Why doesn't the water drip out? Well, look at that.
[SOUND]
>> So, how do you think it works?
What's your conceptual model for the way it works?
>> It's a mystery.
>> Hm, it's supposed to be a mystery. It's called a puzzle-pot. The
Chinese invented a togo about 400 years ago, and this is a copy.
And, you're right, there's no obvious way to put the water in you
don't really want to put it in there, and you turn it upside
down and there's a hole
>> [LAUGH]
>> sure, but come on. You pour the water there, you turn it
upside down, the water will flow out. So, yet, if I do that, whoop,
where does it, how does it work? You're not suppose to be able
to figure it out, that's the whole point, that's why it's called a puzzle-pot.
>> So, this was designed by a trickster. A
good designer, and this is the challenge for design.
Will design things such that somebody can have
an effective conceptual model and understand how it works.
>> Or, go out of the way so you don't have a model.
>> [LAUGH]
>> If, in fact, that's the goal.
>> You know, to fool you.
>> And the only way a designer can communicate is through the objects
that they design. And there is the challenge, and what this lesson is about.